mom i'm live
okay bye northwest just went live on
tick tock
say yes if you love this app and her mom
kim kardashian isn't happy about it
having kids is just there's no way to
describe it but it's a lot in case you
missed it the eight-year-old recently
joined the social media platform by
launching a joint account with her
famous mom and they've delivered some
pretty iconic content already holy
spirit activate oh no holy spirit
activate
going in and out
[Music]
while the account is obviously monitored
by the kkw beauty founder north took
matters into her own hands over the
weekend and gave an impromptu house tour
live on tick tock
wait say yes say yes if you want to see
the thing yes say yes say yes oh this
girl said yes two yeses yes yes three
two
one
wow
wow
some new thing movies
the cake
so we're the porcupine
and then the big lion whatever this is
we're going to see what it
this
oh some
so let's go
let's show my
my my good thing my house
let's give a house tour my christmas
tree that i did some tick tocks with
yeah the tour kicked off with north
showing off her bedroom and the sing two
screening that the kardashian kids got
to enjoy this weekend but then north
spilled the beans telling kim who was in
bed that she had in fact gone live on
tick tock i have so much views yeah
no
no no more views no more views lives
alive not a lot of being live not
allowed to be like not allowed to be
live smart
oh my god
mom i'm live
[Music]
but before the eldest west kid got shut
down her cousin kourtney kardashian's
six-year-old son rain made an appearance
no not fair live live tick tock live
live live live chicken fry live she's a
gemini so she's a little bit of both she
definitely has kanye's outgoing
personality and then she's also really
calm and sweet like me sometimes kim and
north previously posted this home tour
video showing off all their christmas
decor look closely that right there is a
stalking for kim's ex and the father of
her four children kanye west of course
kim filed for divorce back in february
and e.t has learned the reality star
filed documents on friday to be declared
legally single and she's asking for west
to be dropped from her last name but it
seems the 44 year old rapper still wants
kim back at his benefit concert in la
last week kanye performed his hit run
away and changed up the lyrics to shout
out his ex
[Applause]
[Music]
and it isn't the first time yays
expressed his desire to reconcile here's
what he said last month on the drink
champs podcast
my kids want their parents to stay
together i want their parents i want us
to be together but if you want to be
together too if you look at the media
that's not what they promoting
that's not what they want they want it
to be a new way and a new episode a new
tv show and then they have people all
around and my wife here i always believe
and trust in him that he will
always eventually explain himself
because i know his heart all this comes
amid kim's budding romance with snl
comedian pete davidson a source
previously told et the two are 100
dating and having a great time together
but still a second source said kim is
trying to be sensitive towards kanye kim
has been protective of kanye and his
feelings and has been trying to keep her
hangouts with pete low key because she
doesn't know how he will react i'm just
extremely happy can you tell by my face
meanwhile the beauty mogul has a lot to
celebrate because she's one step closer
to adding lawyer to her resume on monday
kim announced on instagram that after
three failed attempts she officially
passed to the baby bar telling her
followers don't ever give up even when
you are holding on by a thread you can
do it